thank you
all right
before we started in two minutes
upstairs
thank you
guys
hi we need to keep this aisle clear
don't have a steel camera sitting near
the aisle I
asked that I want them to usually
good afternoon
thank you for joining us here today
earlier this afternoon Donald Trump was
arraigned on a New York Supreme Court
indictment
returned by a Manhattan grand jury
on 34 felony counts of falsifying
business records in the first degree
under New York state law it is a felony
to falsify business records with intent
of Fraud and an intent to conceal
another crime
that is exactly what this case is about
34 false statements
made to cover up other crimes
these are felony crimes in New York
state
no matter who you are
we cannot and will not normalize serious
criminal conducts
the defendant repeatedly made false
statements on New York business records
he also caused others to make false
statements
the defendant claimed that he was paying
Michael Cohen for Legal Services
performed in 2017.
this simply was not true
and it was a false statement that the
defendant made month after month in
2017.
April
May June and so on through the rest of
the year
for nine straight months
the defendant held documents in his hand
containing this key lie
that he was paying Michael Cohen for
Legal Services performed in 2017.
and he personally signed checks for
payments to Michael Cohen for each of
these nine months
in total the grand jury found there were
34 documents with this critical false
statement
why did Donald Trump repeatedly make
these false statements
the evidence will show that he did so to
cover up crimes relating to the 2016
election
Donald Trump
Executives at the Publishing Company
American Media Incorporated
Mr Cohen and others agreed in 2015 to a
catch and kill scheme that is a scheme
to buy and suppress negative information
to help Mr Trump's chance of winning the
election
as part of this scheme Donald Trump and
others made three payments to people who
claim to have negative information about
Mr Trump
to make these payments they set up shell
companies
and they made yet more false statements
including for example an Ami American
Media incorporators
business records
one of the three people that they paid
to keep quiet was a woman named Stormy
Daniels
less than two weeks before the
presidential election Michael Cohen
wired 130 000 to Stormy Daniels lawyer
that payment was the high damaging
information from the voting public
the participant scheme was illegal
the scheme violated New York election
law which makes it a crime to conspire
to promote a candidacy by unlawful means
the 130 000 wire payment exceeded the
federal campaign contribution cap
and the false statements in Ami's books
violated New York law
that is why Mr Trump made false
statements about his payments to Mr
Cohen
he cannot simply say that the payments
were a reimbursement for Mr Cohen's
payments
to Sandy to Stormy Daniels
to do so to make that true statement
would have been to emit a crime
so instead Mr Trump said that he was
paying Mr Cohen for fictitious legal
services in 2017 to cover up actual
crime
committed the prior year
and in order to get Michael Cohen his
money back
they planned one last false statement
in order to complete the scheme they
plan to mischaracterize the repayments
to Mr Cohen as income
to the New York state tax authorities
the conduct I just described and that
which
was charged by the grand jury is felony
criminal conduct in New York state
true and accurate business records are
important everywhere to be sure
they are all the more important in
Manhattan
the financial center of the world
that is why we have a history in the
Manhattan DA's Office of vigorously
enforcing white-collar crime
my office including The Talented
prosecutors you saw at arraignment
earlier today has charged hundreds of
felony falsifying business records
this charge it can be said is the bread
and butter of our White Collar work
and fraud presents itself in all
different forms here in Manhattan we've
charged falsifying business records for
those who violated Federal Bank secrecy
laws
we have charged false client business
records for those who were seeking to
cover up sex crimes and we have brought
this charge for those
who committed tax violations
at its core
this case today is one with allegations
like so many of our White Collar cases
allegations that someone lied again and
again to protect their interests and
evade the laws to which we are all held
accountable
as this office is done time and time
again we today uphold our solemn
responsibility to ensure that everyone
stands equal before the law
no amount of money and no amount of
power changes that enduring American
principle
I'll now take questions right
we conducted a thorough and rigorous
investigation as we're known to do at
the Manhattan District Attorney's office
I've been doing this for 24 years and
I'm no stranger to rigorous complex
investigations I bring cases when
they're ready
having now conducted a rigorous thorough
investigation the case was ready to be
brought and it was brought
business so
records
and they would not conceal another crime
but indictment does not specifically say
what those crimes were we are assuming
perhaps that they might be electrolated
I'm wondering if you can
specifier what laws were also broken
right so let me let me say as an initial
matter the indictment doesn't specify
that because the law does not so require
uh in my remarks I mentioned a couple of
laws which I will highlight again now uh
the the first is New York state election
law which makes it a crime to conspire
to promote a candidacy by unlawful means
I further indicated a number of unlawful
means including more additional false
statements including statements that
were planned to be made to tax
authorities
I also noted the federal election law
cap on Contraband contribution uh limits
well we we I'm not going to go into our
delivery process on what was brought the
charges that were brought with the ones
that were brought the evidence and the
law uh is is the basis for those
decisions
what was
in order to bring a case
I'm not going to go chapter and verse
into many thinking what I will say is I
believe the time period you're talking
about I've been in office for a couple
of months the
investigation in my view was not
concluded into the conduct in particular
that is the base for the charges today
since that time we've had more evidence
made available to the office and
opportunity to meet with additional
Witnesses so as I said earlier I've been
doing this for 24 years I don't bring
cases prior to a thorough and rigas
investigation now having done so the
case has been brought
this is Brad Garrett hake with NBC News
your predecessor took a hard look at
this case and decided not to charge it
Federal prosecutors took a hard look at
do you believe you have new evidence
that led you to decide to charge this or
why now well as I just mentioned we have
had available to the office additional
evidence that was not in the office's
possession prior to my time here and as
to uh your part of your question about
the the federal we have a distinct and
strong I would say profound independent
interest in New York State this is the
business capital of the world we
regularly do cases involving false
business statements uh the the the
bedrock in fact the basis for uh
business integrity and a
well-functioning business Marketplace is
true and accurate record keeping that's
the charge that's brought here
falsifying New York State business
records
Trump was one
I'm not going to go beyond the plain
language statement of factors I think
speaks for itself
so the the charge is false fine business
records uh the charge requires as I as I
uh specified uh
criminal conduct that was concealed uh
one of the concealed crimes we allege is
New York state election law uh I sort of
went through in our statement of facts I
think many of you have in front of you
um you know goes through things
including
um you know text messages emails
contemporaneous phone records multiple
Witnesses all of that uh will be as you
saw in the fall uh born out in a public
courtroom uh in downtown Manhattan
also mentions another
woman really smells in dormant and you
comment on how those players are related
it's it's a
I'm glad you put your your finger on
that because it's not just about
one payment uh it is 34 business records
uh 34 false statements and business
records
and we're concealing criminal conduct
um and uh the earlier question about New
York state election law when we talked
about conspiracy uh to to promote a
candidacy by unlawful means those are
lawful means we allege include uh the
conduct uh you know set forth in the
statement of facts which is you know
additional false statements separate
apart from the charge ones in Ami
documents planned false statements to
taxing authorities it is not just uh
that one one 130 000 wire payment thanks
so much